yo you were at strip hop with Nipsey
yeah yeah yeah so this is like the
legendary grinding on my life uh the
line that he says yeah and and if you at
the time I was living there I remember
hearing about it that was that the night
that got trip hop closed
or was that a different night I think it
was a different night it was a different
night yeah yeah that led to it because I
think I remember the night that actually
ended up getting it closed I think
someone died right yeah somebody got
shot right now right in front of the
[__] door yeah so give us the the
night you were there with Nipsey what
happened tell us about that night man
that night it was just wild I think um
you kind of feel it in the air when you
came in and something was going to pop
off right you know what I'm saying for
people who don't know because there is
some context here strip Hop was a Vegas
strip club that was at Deja Vu or was
that it was at seamless days it was it
was it was right across the street from
New Orleans yeah and it was open for
maybe six months but in no six months it
was legendary Rick Ross was in there 50
was I mean it was insane all right so
yeah okay tell us about the night with
nip
um
and I ain't gonna lie man that night
like you can feel it in the air
Something's Gonna Pop Up I had already I
had already felt like that going there
and then um
I remember
this chick I was dealing with was in
there
and I was I hang on in front I was
talking to her and trying to get her and
her friend to come with me that night
and then uh I seen like her like go like
this
so I'm like what the hell then it was
just chaotic after that a little bit so
what happened was it a shootout was it
at first just to fight and then you know
people ran out of there started you know
somebody got in there with a gun of
course you know I started shooting so
was this a fight involving Nipsey or was
Nipsey just there
um I think it was involved in him and
his crew I don't think he was actually
involved in it at first but you know as
things starting to spread out people
spreading out people just start punching
and socking on people as they just take
a [__] free-for-all yeah that's what
ended up happening for real food I don't
want to put too much on because I know
both parties right you know what I'm
saying you know both sides so they're
with nip or were you just have to be
there the same night I wasn't there with
him but you know we uh
we both used to record in Mall Studio
yeah at his house yeah when you know
before all that other stuff happened so
that was a crazy house to be at yeah it
was it was one of the more legendary
places I frequented in my life